with just one click you can shop online
make online bake transfers like a post
on instagram
and much more as convenient and exciting
as it sounds
have you ever wondered how unsafe it
could be to live in this digital era
is our data well protected well no
to help us tackle this issue we have
cyber security to our rescue
cyber security is the art of protecting
our networks and devices from
unauthorized access when i say
unauthorized access here
it would refer to a small or big cyber
attack or
a cyber threat there are various types
of cyber attacks that you can fall prey
to
phishing malware attack ddos attack
password attack and many more a few ways
to implement cyber security are defining
clear boundaries
using network security control devices
like firewalls and ids
and carrying out security testing at any
point in time the cia that is
confidentiality
integrity and availability are being
implemented in an organization to ensure
that our information is
secure there is a great demand for
professionals like ethical hackers
cisos and many more cyber security
experts who can implement cyber security
and safeguard an organization's data so
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and begin your
lucrative cybersecurity career
this was cyber security in short if you
enjoyed this video give it a thumbs up
and hit the subscribe button
i'll be back with more exciting videos
so watch out for them
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn